today's episode is sponsored by - Layne
Troy - Layne for free on your first
device and when you decide to upgrade to
premium use my code biographic s-- to
get a 10% discount on premium more on
them in a bit
[Music]
those are the chilling words of a man
who put his belief into practice the
Zodiac killer he terrorized the San
Francisco Bay Area throughout the late
1960s and early 1970s and was never
caught or identified he popularized for
lack of a better word several tropes
that we associate with serial killers
today and we find in numerous crime
shows movies and books taunting the
police giving himself a unique name and
using the media to feed his craving for
attention he disappeared without a trace
and 50 years of investigation have
yielded only one solid suspect but not
enough evidence to arrest like Jack the
Ripper the Zodiac seems to guarantee to
remain one of the biggest question marks
in the annals of criminal history on
December 20th 1968 17 year-old David
Arthur Faraday climbed into his Rambler
station wagon and went to pick up 16
year-old Betty Lou Jensen they had only
known each other for a couple of weeks
they went to different high schools in
Vallejo a city located within the San
Francisco Bay Area and this was supposed
to be their first date David went by the
Jensen home to meet Betty news parents
afterwards the couple stopped by a
friend's house on their way to a concert
their last stop of the night was the
secluded area along Lake Herman Road
which was the popular Lovers Lane for
the local teen the two of them were
hoping for some privacy but another car
soon pulled up alongside them a dark
figure walked out and approached
Faraday's Rambler he pulled out a 22
caliber semi-automatic weapon and shot
the vehicle purportedly to get the high
schoolers to exit
David Faraday was his first target the
killer shot him once in the head that he
looped Jensen had time to make a run for
it but she didn't get very far
her body was found 28 feet from the car
shot five times in the back
Faraday was still alive when a passing
motorist stumbled onto the crime scene
but he died before he reached the
hospital the Zodiac killer had claimed
his first victims of course nobody knew
us at that point the first detectives
who were assigned to the case
investigated it just like any other
double homicide Jensen's best friend
later criticized the officers saying
that they'd already made up their minds
that the killings had been drugged
somehow and refused to pursue any other
areas of investigation they looked at an
ex-boyfriend at betty-lou but he was at
home watching a movie with his family on
the night of the murders they
investigated to local Seward but out
that night hunting raccoons but their
guns didn't match the murder weapon they
also heard that two white men spent the
night scaring teenagers by chasing them
around in a blue sedan but they were
never identified it wasn't until after
the holidays when the typical leads
dried up that investigators concluded
that the killings were in fact the work
of a murderous maniac who had no
connection to the victims a few months
later the new hypothesis was confirmed
when he killed gain
[Music]
on July the 4th 1969 a very similar
scenario unfolded when the gunman pulled
his car behind a couple pots in another
secluded area this time the Blue Rock
Springs Golf Course just a few miles
away from the first crime scene these
victims were a little older Michel Magoo
was 19 years old while his girlfriend's
Darlene Ferrin was 22 the killer got out
of his car and pointed a flashlight at
the couple so they couldn't see him
first they thought he was a police
officer so they got all their IDs as he
approached that car however as soon as
he reached the driver side window he
started shooting
he fired five shots inside the car in
and simply turned around and slowly made
his way back to his own vehicle however
the heard Michel Magoo moaning in pain
and realizing that he was still alive he
went back and put two more bullets into
each body before leaving the scene less
than an hour later the Viejo Police
Department received a call traced to a
phone booth just a few blocks away from
the station the man on the line said I
wish to report a double murder if one of
you will go a mile east on Columbus
Parkway to a public park you will find
the kids in a brown car they've been
shot by a 9-millimeter Luger I also
killed those kids last year goodbye as
it turns out the police were already
aware of the shooting a few teenagers
had found the couple just minutes after
the killer left and this ended up saving
Michael Mageau his life Darlene Ferrin
was pronounced dead at the hospital but
the goat survived the attack
not only that but he saw his attacker
because the shooter didn't bother to
hold up the flashlight the second time
around he described the killer as a
white man in his late 20s early 30s
short around five eight or five nine
with a stocky build brown hair and a
round face
it didn't take long before the murderer
made his presence known again but this
time however he didn't kill more people
instead he reached out to the media on
August the first less than a month after
the attack on McGowan fairing three
newspapers from the Bay Area received
letters from the killer they were the
San Francisco Chronicle the San
Francisco Examiner and the Viejo Times
Herald the letters were almost identical
and the criminal used them to take
credit for those shootings they differed
in one way the killer had created a 408
symbol cryptogram which is a puzzle made
using encrypted text he split it into
three and sent each newspaper one part
telling them that solving the cryptogram
will reveal his identity he also
demanded that all the newspapers
published their sections on the front
page otherwise he would cruise around
all weekend killing lone people in the
night and then moving on to kill again
until irons with a dozen people over the
weekends The Chronicle did not obey his
instructions instead publishing their
cryptogram on page four alongside a
quote from the Viejo police chief saying
that they're not confirms that the
letters came from the real killer and
asking for more information to prove his
identity
the gunman did not act on his threat
instead he gave in to the request of the
police chief and wrote another letter
this time only to the examiner in which
he included details about the murders
that were not public knowledge there was
no doubt anymore that this killer was
also the author but there was something
else notable about this particular
letter it began with the chilling words
dear Editor this is the zodiac speaking
it was the first time that he gave
himself the name that would go on to
become one of the most infamous words in
criminal history
he soon accompanied by a crosshair
symbol which he often used as his
signature thus making zodiac perhaps the
only serial killer who had his own logo
going back to the cryptogram usually
referred to as the Z 408 cipher it
actually didn't take long for somebody
to crack it less than a week after it
was published a couple of amateur
cryptologists named Donald and Betty
hardened from sound ask contacted the
San Francisco Chronicle to tell them
they had the solution via cryptography
buffs out there the way the hardened
solved the cipher was by finding a few
cribs a crib is a word or phrase which
you suspect from
the outset will appear in the message in
this case Betty hardened is a bit of
clever profiling on the creator of the
cryptogram she reasons that given the
zodiacs craving for attention the
message will begin with the one word
letter I
she was also set and that's the word
kill or killing had to appear somewhere
perhaps even the phrase I like killing
turns out betty was right on the money I
like killing were the first three words
in the cipher once she knew that
deciphering the rest of the message was
just a matter of time as far as the
content was concerned it wasn't the big
breakthrough investigators were hoping
for
despite his promise the zodiac was not
foolish enough to include his identity
in the message instead he talked about
how he enjoyed killing and that he
planned to continue to do it so that his
victims would become his slaves when he
is reborn in Paradise and giving his
name would only slow him down the whole
message was coherent albeit rife with
spelling errors except for the last
group of 18 letters which appeared to be
gibberish if there is some hidden
meaning behind them we haven't figured
it out yet
and speaking of cryptograms and
cryptography - Lane - Lane is today's
sponsor and it's a one-stop shop for all
of your digital identity protection
needs if all your passwords are the same
that's a bad idea
you can use - Lions password manager to
create and securely store complex and
unique passwords making it less likely
that your accounts are gonna get
compromised they also have a VPN as part
of their service meaning that you can
browse the Internet securely and
confidently even on public Wi-Fi but not
just that they also actively monitor the
dark web to see if your information has
been leaked somewhere that means you can
just go in and change your passwords
before someone breaks into other
accounts that share that same password
blast - Lane does what it's always done
it stores your passwords it keeps your
personal data secure it fills all of
those annoying boxes for payment info or
passwords for you so make your life
easier and tet2 - Lane comm forward
slash biographic Stu tried Ashley in for
free on your first device and when you
decide he wants upgrade to premium use
my code biographic Stu get a discount of
10% and let's continue with today's
video
[Music]
the little exchange he had with the
media did not hold the zodiac for long
in the following month he was ready to
claim more victims on September the 27th
1969 he attacked a college couple who
were picnicking by Lake Berryessa in
Napa County California 22 year old
Cecelia Shepard and 20 year old brown
heart nor were approached by a man who
matched the description given by Michael
Mageau as he made his way towards the
couple with a gun in his hands he but on
a strange black hood like something an
execution would wear it also had the
zodiac crosshair symbol on the front and
the gun meant complemented it with a
pair of sunglasses he told the couple
that see was an escaped convict and that
he intended to simply rob them and steal
their car this might have allowed them
to lower their guard somewhat as they
were tied up once they were immobilized
the Zodiac pulled out a knife and
stabbed them both multiple times
afterwards he hiked up to where hot
mullet parked his car using a felt-tip
pen he wrote on the door Vallejo 12:00
xx 68 7/4
69 September 27 69 6:30 by knife these
were the dates of all the killings
clearly even if he used a knife instead
of a gun this time he did not want
anyone to think that somebody else
committed these murders but this was
still not enough later that day he
called the police again and said I want
to report a murder no a double murder
they are two miles north of Park
headquarters they were in a white
Volkswagen Karmann Ghia I'm the one who
did it
once again the Zodiac made the call from
a phone booth just a few blocks away
from the police department that he was
calling it was becoming pretty clear
that taunting the authorities and
showing them that he was smarter was
almost as important as the killings
themselves just like before
one of the victims survived the attack
both Shepherd and Hartnell were still
alive when they were discovered they
were taken to hospital that Shepherd
succumbed to her injuries or heart nor
made a recovery the last known zodiac
killing took place two weeks later in
the middle of San Francisco on October
the 11th cab driver Paul Stine was
murdered on the job a white man who
matched the previous descriptions of the
zodiac got into his cab and asked to be
taken near Presidio park once they
reached their destination the passenger
shot Stine one
in the head afterwards he took the
victim's keys his wallet and cut off the
piece of his shirt
the killer was seen by multiple
witnesses as he walked away and they
were able to give a description the
murder was so different from the rest
that nobody initially suspected that the
zodiac was the culprit they thought it
was just a regular robbery that
escalated to homicide
however like before the killer took
steps to ensure that nobody else would
get credit for his work Paul Stine is
the last murder definitively attributed
to the zodiac we're getting two other
possible victims in a bit but for now we
noticed that as soon as the killings
stopped zodiacs communication with the
media increased he sent over two dozen
letters in the following years his next
one arrived at the San Francisco
Chronicle just a few days after Stein's
death alongside a piece of the cab
drivers shirt to prove that he was the
killer zodiac also mocked the San
Francisco Police Department for its
inability to catch him and ended the
letter with an ominous threat he said
schoolchildren make nice targets I think
I shall wipe out a school bus some
warning just shoot out the front R and
then pick off the kiddies as they come
bouncing out fortunately the zodiac
never followed up on this threat but his
words and the desired effect of causing
terror and chaos in the city even
spurring talks of cancelling school
altogether it was becoming more and more
evident to the people investigating as
murders that what the zodiac enjoyed
most was feeding off the public fear and
attention perhaps he even enjoyed this
more than the killing
after all he rarely bothered to even
check of his targets were dead after he
attacked them on the other hand he
always went to great lengths and even
risked getting caught in order to ensure
that everybody knew that he was the one
responsible a very strange episode
occurred the following week when someone
alleging to be the zodiac called the
police again and demanded that either f
lee Bailey or Melvin belli two of the
most famous lawyers in the country
appear on a talk show called a.m. San
Francisco hosted by Jim Dunbar belli
complied went on the show and eagerly
waited alongside Dunbar for the Zodiac
to call the suspects actually did call
not once not twice but 54 times in two
hours
each time he would only say a few words
hang up wait a bit and then phone again
eventually he agreed to turn himself in
and arranged for a surrender location in
Daly City it probably won't surprise you
to discover that he never showed up
although to be fair it was never
established with any certainty that the
caller was the actual killer and not
just some guide looking for his 15
minutes of fame
the real zodiac did get in touch soon
after this time with a letter containing
another cipher referred to as Z 340
while the first cipher took about 20
hours to crack this one remains unsolved
even today 50 years later two more
ciphers followed one of them Zed Burton
was really short and only had 13 symbols
which were preceded by the words
my name is this last one was the most
complex of all and also included a map
of the Bay Area alongside instructions
on how to use it correctly if solved it
would have led to the location of a bomb
buried somewhere near Mount Diablo
neither of these ciphers was ever solved
conclusively either it's possible they
were never meant to be solves and that
they were just full of gibberish some
cryptologists argue that the zodiac
significantly increased the difficulty
of his ciphers after the first one was
solved so quickly while others believed
he filled them with random symbols to
make sure that nobody could crack them
and therefore nobody could show that
they were smarter than him
[Music]
like with most other serial killers
investigators have to consider the
possibility that the zodiac had other
victims
indeed they suspected that he might have
started killing as early as 1963 and
that's he continued after the death of
Paul Stine in the last ever letter he
sent to the media the Zodiac bragged
about having 37 victims mailed on
January the 29th 1974 it is known as The
Exorcist letter because the killer
starts off praising the movie The
Exorcist as the best satirical comedy
that I have ever seen
he ends it by writing me 37 SFPD 0 not a
lot of people actually think the zodiac
had that many victims for starters he
already made plenty of other claims and
threats that were false like attacking
the school bus or the bomb buried near
the mountain but more importantly with
his five known victims the Zodiac always
seemed to take extra steps to ensure
that people knew he did it would he
murder dozens of other people without
taking credit or was this simply just
another throwaway line to make himself
feel superior to the authorities
regardless of what his profile might
have suggested the police couldn't
dismiss possible zodiac victims just
because they didn't fit his behavior the
first murders that caught their
attention took place in 1963 the
high-school couple of Robert Dominguez
and Linda Edwards who were shot to death
on a remote beach near the town of
Gaviota not only that but the same kind
of weapon and type of ammunition we used
as in the attack on David Faraday and
Betty Lou Jensen contrary to the zodiac
though this killer wanted to get rid of
the bodies by placing them in a run-down
old shack and trying unsuccessfully to
light them on fire another suspicious
case was the murder of 18 year-old Cheri
Jo Bates in 1966 she was stabbed to
death an alley on the campus of
Riverside City College the Zodiac did
eventually take credit for her death and
one of his many letters but this
happened in 1971 only after the media
publicized her story there was also the
attempted kidnapping of Kathleen Jones
and her infant daughter on March the
22nd 1970 a car broke down and she was
picked up by a strange man he said that
he would drop her off at a gas station
that he kept driving past one gas
station after another Jones became
nervous enough that she ran out of the
car when the man stops in an
intersection and hid in a field the
stranger came looking for her with a
flashlight but eventually gave
than laughed later at the police station
Jones recognized the composite of the
man who killed Paul Stine as the same
person who picked her up the last case
that warrants mentioned was the
disappearance of a nurse named Donna
lass in 1970 her body was never found
but a Zodiac style letter where she was
referred to as victim 12 and contained
details regarding her location was sent
to journalist Paul Avery from the San
Francisco Chronicle it is possible that
the zodiac indeed killed this woman or
it is also possible that he was once
again lying to make himself feel more
important the third and most interesting
idea suggested that the letter was
written by the actual killer
deliberately imitating the style of the
Zodiac to make him take the blame for it
[Music]
so now we arrive at the big question who
was the zodiac in the decades following
his murders over 2,500 suspects have
been investigated yet none of them have
ever been arrested or charged with
anything we might as well start with the
biggest one of all Arthur Leigh Allen a
convicted child molester who lived in
Vallejo to this day he remains the only
suspect ever named publicly by the
police Robert gray-smith a cartoonist
who worked for The Chronicle at the time
of the killings and who wrote two
definitive books on the zodiac case also
named Arthur Leigh Allen as being the
murderer there was evidence for Allen as
the Zodiac he owned a pair of boots
identical to those of the killer and a
watch with the crosshairs symbol on it
he was even identified out of a photo
lineup by one of the surviving victims
of the zodiac however the photo ID
occurred many years after the attack and
a questionable DNA test back in 2002
they have exonerated him although he was
later deemed inconclusive
the problem with DNA in this case is
that there are no good reliable samples
officers back in the 60s and 70s that no
way of knowing that DNA would end up
becoming so importance in the future so
the evidence was handled poorly and
Taine's it there was some renewed hope a
few years back after the Golden State
killer was finally identified using a
genealogy website investigators hopes
that the same thing would happen for the
zodiac so they resubmitted for analysis
stamps that had been licked by the
killer to see if they could obtain a
full DNA profile however this
was back in late 2018 no new
developments were ever announced so
presumably an analysis didn't work
Arthur Leigh Allen died in 1992 of a
heart attack and many people remain
convinced that he was in fact the zodiac
one of those people was David Toschi the
chief investigator on the case we should
take a quick moment to mention him more
in depth as he was quite a character
himself he had the reputation of being a
tough guy although he enjoyed wearing
bowties and colorful jackets he served
as inspiration for Dirty Harry as well
as Steve McQueen's character and Bullitt
he had an ignominious and bizarre
departure from the zodiac case in 1978
when it was discovered that he had been
sending letters under fake names to San
Francisco newspapers praising himself
and the work that he was doing on the
case at one point he was even suspected
of forging a zodiac letter but this idea
was later dismissed
like we said Allen was the only suspect
the police ever named but this did not
stop other amateur sleuths from
advancing all sorts of ideas many of
them claimed that other notorious
killers like BDK or the Unabomber were
also the zodiac one former detective
wrote a book where he advanced the
outlandish hypothesis that a convicted
serial killer by the name of Edward
Edwards was responsible for many other
infamous unsolved murders this includes
the Zodiac killings but also the black
dahlia John Bennett Ramsey and Jimmy
Hoffa then there are a bunch of people
who have come forth in recent years
claiming that their deceased fathers or
acquaintances had been the zodiac Jack
Terrence George Hodel guy Ward
Hendrickson Lewis Mars have all been
advanced to suspects by people who knew
them closely each one comes with enough
proof to make them possible candidates
but nowhere close enough to confirm them
there are so many questions that remain
unanswered did the zodiac truly stop
killing why did he stop writing letters
do his unsolved ciphers actually contain
any useful information was Arthur Leigh
Allen the killer all along it seems like
the zodiac is just destined to remain a
mystery forever so I really hope you
found their video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe also
please do check out our wonderful
sponsor - Lane who I'm linking to below
and thank you for watching
[Music]